dorénavant les élèves n'auront
absolument plus le droit de fumer dans
l'établissement y compris dans les cours
les vacances sont terminées et depuis le
10 septembre les cours ont repris mais
savez-vous comment s'est passé la
pré-entrée de vos professeurs un jour
avant vous le 9 septembre giga suivi
Anne professeur d'histoire et géographie
au lycée Buffon à Paris dans cet
établissement le jour de la pré-rentrée
les élèves sont également présents afin
de consulter leur emploi du temps nous
leur avons demandé comment leur avis ça
se passe dans la tête des profs
[Musique]
comme notre entrée à nous c'est pareil
ancestral parce qu'ils disent qu'ils
vont trouver des petits monstres et que
ça les fait bien chier
[Musique]
alors les monstres ça dépend toutes les
classes ne sont pas constituées de
monstres heureusement c'est pas le trac
c'est
l'attente savoir quels seront les
classes de qui elles seront composées je
pense que le trac est important quand on
arrive dans un établissement là on ne
sait pas quand on revient bah il y a des
élèves qu'on connaît donc on sait que ce
ne sont pas tous des monstres quand même
[Musique]
et avec les collègues ça se passe
comment on se raconte nos vacances
comment vont les familles de chacun et
puis les contacts sont essentiellement
avec ce qu'on aime bien on n'a pas de
compte ici il y a 150 professeurs même
le jour de la pré-entrée on ne dit pas
bonjour à tout le monde
ça doit être ma 17e ou 18e à rentrer
donc elle se prépare le programme se
prépare
évidemment mais psychologiquement je
dois avouer que j'ai pas eu un grand
effort à faire
chaque année il y a l'inconnu de
l'emploi du temps de l'organisation on
ne sait pas toujours les classes que
l'on aura donc toujours cette part
d'inconnu et puis aussi il y a une
forme de d'excitation les dés de
reprendre de retrouver à la fois des
visages connus ou au contraire inconnus
une espèce d'excitation des enfants ont
aussi je crois que nous sommes encore de
grands adolescents quelque part
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
croire la journée de pré-rentrée est
très chargée pour les professeurs
[Musique]
voilà un autre sportif c'est un peu le
parcours du combattant il doit passer
chez le proviseur prendre des
renseignements passer chez le proviseur
adjoint prendre son emploi du temps
assister à une réunion pour les
consignes générales comme vous l'avez vu
aussi dans la salle de spectacle tout à
l'heure puis ensuite il a des réunions
de spécialités ou bien sur des thèmes
précis alors en ce moment ce sont les
modules d'entrée en seconde il y a aussi
eu des réunions en 6e pour l'évaluation
de 6e et puis il y a eu aussi des
réunions ce n'est pas encore terminé
tout à l'heure on y va sur le projet
d'établissement bref la journée remplie
de réunions pour le professeur
avant les réunions entre prof de même
matière un petit intermède fraîcheur
s'impose
[Musique]
nous sommes en pleine période de
Maastricht comment fait-on pour insérer
ce genre d'actualité dans le programme
soit les élèves posent des questions ils
sont demandeurs à ce moment-là on répond
à la demande on coupe la moi je coupe le
goût je prends une heure deux heures là
dessus s'il y en a qui veulent faire un
exposé de fond si d'autres ont des
questions à poser pour me faire un débat
on le fait s'ils sont demandeurs si ils
ne vendent rien si c'est moi je ne le
fait que dans les classes où il y a le
programme
avez-vous reçu des consignes
particulières pour cette rentrée 92
on nous demande d'être particulièrement
vigilant ce qui concerne les graffitis
parce que parce que les graffitis ça
coûte très cher à retirer et donc les
élèves que nous prendrons sur le fait
seront vraiment punis et seront
financièrement punis on fera appel
à l'argent de leur part
parmi les nouvelles consignes le plus
important c'est peut-être que dorénavant
les élèves n'auront absolument plus le
droit de fumer dans l'établissement y
compris dans les cours et ça a
d'ailleurs des implications pour les
professeurs aussi puisque
nous ne serons plus autorisés à fumer
quand celle des professeurs et encore si
la majorité le tolère
[Musique]